all right don't be rude in the middle
copy
hey so baby brother what's new
can you not call me a baby in public I'm
like 23 years old all right you're gonna
want a turn turn turn turn park hit no
wait don't park here you don't know how
to parallel park go straight go straight
I am what do you think I'm doing right
now Ryan's here with me mom hooky not be
the baby with that baby face no you know
I did better than you on your driving
test what about it okay that's just
hurtful
did you see these photos of mom post it
no these are all of you yeah
are there any of me sure looks familiar
um yeah Devin gave it to me as a hammock
down it would go good with that cat hat
actually stay away from the cat hat
right there
oh oh I look so sad and constipated not
much has changed okay
hey if we go to that drive for you could
you borrow something I mean I could get
you at a kid's meal like with the toy
you know what fine maybe I'm the baby to
you and the rest of the family but to
the world I'm a man so what can I get
you guys I'll get a lager yeah same ah
this is my defense Ryan I see my cat hat
no okay